hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jessie and today we're going to go
over well we're gonna start with
continuing where we left off yesterday
and then when I get to the question
answer session I want to go over some
changes that I made on project project 2
so I had a meeting this morning and had
some additional project requirements so
I'm not gonna code anything but I just
want to go over a few things that I did
because I think they were they'll be
kind of useful so sorry I didn't have my
camera working when I started it should
be working now I was just reading about
a way to use your phone as your webcam
so if I can get that working I might try
that and then maybe I won't have
problems with the webcam anymore and it
should be a much better picture too
because I think I know I could record 4k
video so I have no idea how many
megapixels my phone is but it's it's
definitely better than my built-in
webcam on my iMac to everyone I see some
people saying hi in the live chat there
so all right let's um let's get started
and let me bring let me bring over my
my timer bring the timer over and let's
organize our windows so you don't have
to flip around so much so we'll bring
over
let's bring over the code here and bring
that over there we go so here's just
what we had so far I think we I think I
accidentally searched so let's go to I
think that was the URL hopefully there
we go that's it all right so this is a
South where we we yesterday doesn't look
like much but we learned a lot about how
this thing is structured so the plan
today is to Pomodoro sessions of code
and then a question answer session I
think when we do that that gives us a
nice about about an hour and a half
at least unless there's like no
questions and then we're maybe we'll be
at like an hour and 15 minutes but I
think that's a nice length a nice length
for the show it gives us a long enough
time to get get something done I get
some questions in but it's not so long
that I think it seems like too daunting
if for someone to watch the replay so
I'm gonna start my first Pomodoro
session after this one's over I'll take
five minutes and answer some questions
so if you ask something in the live chat
and I don't get to it just wait and I
will get to it you know after the timer
is up and then at the end I'll try to
get to every question so if you can
stick around till the end I'll
definitely get your question answered
and no-beard notice that I that I saved
yeah I did out my I was just really busy
with well with work and my family and
the the nanodegree program I just hadn't
shaved in like a week because every time
I got up to get ready
work I was always running late from like
staying up late trying to trying to do
this work so anyway so I finally got the
shape that was nice but let's get
started
let's see we are today going to try to
well first thing we should do is make
this visible right because we're not
really gonna know if we've done anything
right unless this is visible I mean we
can see the we can see here in dev tools
that what we've done is actually being
inserted properly into the Dom but for
some reason we can't see it so let's
figure that out first it hopefully
should only take a few minutes then
we're going to define those find those
points where the data from the content
management system is being inserted into
the current menus and we're going to
take those and we're going to plug them
in with that repeater component that we
found yesterday and we're going to try
to plug them in in our side nav where we
want those fields to be and hopefully
it'll work out that all the links that
were in the other menu are now going to
be in our menu and they're all going to
look right so if if you're not familiar
with what we're doing this is the menu
that we're going for and I'll show you I
can show you the menu that we're coming
from so we're one of this we want the
links to be on the side here also a
search bar there when you click this
it'll actually open up the side knife
and then this side which is taking a
significant amount of time to load this
time you can see this that was that was
insane we didn't even see anything but
white for I wasn't counting but that was
at least five seconds maybe more but
anyway this is our current navigation
and we want to go to this
okay so let's check out just right here
in dev tools what's going on and the
first thing I want to do
let's see where all right work we're out
from here
many contents that's a bunch of stuff
there we go so we're up here everything
below here is the main content which
that's not what we're dealing with right
now we are dealing with the the header
which I guess is inside of here yep
here's our header okay oh you know what
I just remembered now that we never
imported our style so we're gonna use
materialized and we never brought it in
so let's do that
I suspect that once we do that things
are gonna look a lot different let's see
I hope they look a lot different because
they should so let's grab from
materialized the CSS and JavaScript for
now I think I'm just gonna load it from
a CDN might think about probably in the
end we're just gonna host it ourselves
and we're gonna pull out everything that
we're not using to trim it down a bit
but for now we'll go with the CDN and
then that way we'll have access to
everything while we're developing
I think that'll just it'll be faster
than having to go and grab things and
put it I've tried it both ways I've
tried starting with nothing and pulling
in what I want and I try starting with
everything and then pulling out what I
didn't use I think it does go faster if
you start with everything so materialize
there we go getting started okay little
versions one one is coming soon I wonder
how sin but for this I'm fine with I'm
fine with using whatever version where
we have access to okay so this is whoops
I did not want to save would almost
musta hit can command s instead of
command C so I'm gonna copy that and
we'll put that in
now I don't want to put it in here
actually I'm almost kind of thinking
this over just coming from like the
react world so I was working all morning
on react and just thinking of like
importing our styles and things right
into the component that we need I'm
wondering if it would be good to import
the stuff right in this main nav
component that way if there's any pages
we don't use the main nav I guess we
wouldn't now you know it that's that's
nonsense because we're gonna end up
using this throughout so we're gonna use
these styles so if I was only in ez
styles for the main nav it would make
sense that that old thing might not have
made sense I was just kind of thinking
out loud but basically I was I was
thinking that if I put the Styles that I
needed just in that component then I
wouldn't load them on pages where I'm
not using that component but I'm
probably gonna use that same header on
every page and I'll probably use these
styles from materialize for a lot of
other things so I'm just gonna put it in
main master test oops not that one this
one okay so we can see everything else
that we have I'm gonna put these right
now below this is quite a large there we
go I'm gonna put it right at the bottom
so that way I know we're gonna override
a lot of this and then whatever custom
styles we need to use we'll put it under
under these to be able to override the
things and materialize mm-hmm so how
excuse me and that should that should be
good hopefully we can get rid of a lot
of the styles that are that are
so we saw like I know I saw a custom
Styles being imported let's see yeah
here so we have a lot of different
styles coming in you can see at one
point I actually went in and I tried to
clean this up so we have like the all
these bundled I think it was interesting
what I found was that there wasn't it
actually loaded more slowly when I
bundled them all together so that's why
these are commented out not so I'd like
to test it again and and see what
happens because that was kind of odd
that you know they're like that and I
went through and I meant if I'd a lot of
these so a lot of these are the minified
versions even if they don't say men so
but we'll go through a later on after we
get it looking like we want to we'll go
through and try to get rid of as much as
we can
alright so that should have loaded let's
refresh
whoa all right okay so it's looking
pretty bad but we have something on the
on the screen at least so we can see
that we have you know we have some of
these links we have this is an SVG it's
supposed to be the Facebook icon okay so
what we have I do have some Styles that
I did not import it just let my mind
until now that I had made some custom
styles for that header I didn't bring
those in so I need to bring those in I
need to check to see if I did any
JavaScript that I need to bring in as
well and that should help get these you
know down to normal size and get our
colors right however we still have I
think we'll still have some work to do
here because we have some weird stuff
going on I suspect that we'll see what
happens when I bring in the other styles
but I suspect that maybe there's some
conflicts and you know maybe there's
some really specific CSS selectors in
the custom CSS that was already on this
site maybe they used important a lot and
it's overriding some stuff so we'll just
we'll have to deal with that the tricky
part is we have to deal with it in a way
that doesn't mess up other parts of the
site so it's gonna get I don't know it's
gonna be touchy it's it's I don't know I
think it'll be fun though I know it at
my meeting earlier when I told everyone
in my department that I started working
on this they were all excited so that's
that's cool I like to work on projects
like that so we'll be at main that
I guess I can import it here I was once
again trying to decide whether I should
just import this here but I probably
have some styles that I'll end up using
so we need to do is find here we go
here's what we have for the for that nav
so if you remember yesterday we pulled
the mark up for it but not the style so
let's grab our CSS and it looks like
most of this I'm just gonna copy and
paste all of it right now it's not that
much there's some stuff that I don't
need yet but I will need later like the
footer and then the loaders I might keep
the loader we'll see I don't know that
it would make sense on this site I use
it a lot when I have sites with that I
have like client-side navigation but I'm
not sure how well it would work out
we'll see oh okay yeah most of this
makes sense to keep so let's pull this
over and
let's make whoops I'm sorry I went to
the wrong wrong place I have a lot going
on over here on this screen and if we
can make
I wonder where the rest of these files
are our house that is there we go
alright this looks like the place
alright so let's add a file in here new
file we should call this I don't know I
guess it doesn't matter new design I
will call that not not very creative but
it'll work for now I was thinking about
putting something like Jesse's awesome
theme or something but it's not it's the
University site I don't I don't really
want to mess with that okay cool I like
how that looks
it's a little bit different than Adam
just how they how things get highlighted
and it's not bad I wanted I think I want
to try to match my theme that I use an
atom with the theme I used in Visual
Studio code since I'm used to it yeah it
looks a little weird sometimes so I've
been using this other theme for a long
time for years all right so here's our
CSS let's check out the JavaScript see
if we have anything that's going to
apply okay so I have this I like to put
this on all of my sites and at least all
the ones that I'm using jQuery with and
it just keeps the copyright date current
and you know everybody puts a copyright
date in the in the footer
you know we do have some things that
I'll need to use yeah this is I have
those links in the in the top nav when
you click them it automatically opens
that side nav so I'm definitely going to
have to have to do that although I'll
have to check at one point materialize
change their API when it comes to
modal's so I can't remember if I did
this before or after that change
occurred so if the modal is not working
the first thing I'll check is you know
how we're doing this
well then I'll check the materialized
docs because I had that happen on a few
of my sites when I went to up update to
newer versions of materialized all right
let me make sure that coffee that
alright we're gonna do the same thing
we're just gonna make a custom
javascript file so let's see where we're
bringing in the mmm J's vendor well I'll
find this a Jas file so that'll work
there we go alright so let's make a new
file let's call this new design Jas and
then we'll copy that save alright now we
just need to pull these in so I'll just
OOP someone I'll copy this and
I'll make it new design touch a s and so
now we're bringing in our JavaScript and
let's find our CSS and let's I want to I
want to bring this down below so yeah
here's what CSS oops oh this is right I
didn't make it new design dot CSS and
let's do the same thing with our
JavaScript and that'll be it'll be
better we'll have all of our stuff all
together right here at the bottom it'll
be easy for us to find it okay not
indentation and stuff is not pretty
right now what the heck no I gotta
change my settings here might add key is
set to actually tab instead of two
spaces like I usually have it so I need
to need to do some work on that alright
so now let's refresh and see what we
have
okay a lot better not not what we want
yet but it's a lot better okay yeah
we're on our side now it's not working
let's check our console and see what
errors we have all right a lot of stuff
wow that's huge
okay okay we don't have the image that
makes sense
velocity is not defined
smashing
so I know it's not a function okay
all right so we've got a lot of stuff
going on
okay okay I just checked the live chat
Alberto says do you have jQuery imported
above material je s I I don't know let's
check that out yeah actually we do so we
have we have this above let's check them
it materialized Docs and see if we need
a certain version of jQuery
Wow okay so it's saying jQuery 3.2.1 I
don't want to have to use multiple
versions of jQuery I don't really know
what the compatibility is I mean we
could try we could try to pull in this
jQuery and see you know what I'm a
little bit worried too about this side
nav is not a function so let's check out
the documentation
dear
so now there we go
okay well so that is in there it's it's
still it's still side nav
interesting
well
all right let's let's check on that
modal right now while we have the dogs
open okay I do have the newer yes so we
initialize it with dot modal okay it
should be all right then
okay all right this is gonna be it's
gonna be some work all right well let's
just go through let's check what version
of jQuery I was using and what version
materialized I was using on this other
this oversight here
okay so this was that that demo site I
showed at the beginning that had the
version of the header that we want
I'm gonna check I'm hoping that in
somewhere I have a version number maybe
maybe I'm pulling it from the CDN here
oh it's it's possible that the code I
just copied over the JavaScript have
some es6 stuff that's not working I'll
have to double-check materialise okay
ninety-eight point we could try pulling
this version of materialized in to see
if if this works better with what we
have I mean I'd rather use the newer
version if I can but just to get things
working at first to try to narrow down
the problem I'll bring this in and then
Oh comment didn't work off the check
what's the hotkey to comment in Visual
Studio code I don't know what am i
showing this I'm sure this is plain text
maybe that's why let's highlight this as
HTML yes there we go
now let's see if the comment works ok
now it works that makes sense ok let's
try this then hopefully this address
works for the CDN I don't see why it
wouldn't and now let's give it a restart
and that'll be the last thing we do
before I had set the five-minute timer
Wow I think we actually have more errors
now
okay we did get rid of at least one
thing that was up there so maybe we
don't have more maybe they're just in a
different order that's done you know
there's not a function
I should check to see how many of these
errors are happening anyway and yeah
actually it will do that after we do all
our five minutes a Question and Answer
I'm just gonna comment out the things
that we've imported and I'm I'm going to
see how many errors we have just
naturally because some of these may not
even be our fault alright so let's take
five minute break for questions I'm just
going to scroll up to the top of the
live chat and go on down the list do as
many as I can
James says hi there what are you working
on just came in here we have an existing
site so Franciscan ddu is our existing
site it's built on a really old content
management system that's a dotnet
framework based the system's called
Ektron and I have to work within that
system to try to make it look nicer be
more user friendly and most importantly
load faster so right now we're just
we're we're working from the top down
basically and we've started with the
header actually we might the next thing
we might do is the footer and then we'll
work on the middle we'll see but we just
started with the header and working on
the side nav as well and so we have hmm
sorry this is a big yawn I don't know
why I'm yawning so much I got it I got
sleep finally last night so anyway we
have HTML CSS JavaScript c-sharp some
dotnet template things that I don't
really know enough about dotnet or a
cron to know whether or not this is
Ektron specific stuff or whether this is
stuff that's common to everything built
with dartnet I don't really know but
we've been working through and
to figure it out and I'm gonna try to
make the best of what we can with this
site to try to buy us some time until I
can clear out the schedule well really
my boss can clear out my schedule so I
can redo the site completely
Sarris Manny says free code camp is
amazing yeah it is isn't it and I say
that not to say myself is amazing but
the everybody the organization as a
whole is amazing a lot of awesome
volunteers just doing great stuff
okay else also says I'm doing my
intermediate projects check it out do
you have advice for someone who's
starting in free code camp my advice if
you're starting with the free code camp
lessons is do a little bit every day
it's much better to work for for it an
hour or half-hour every day then - once
a week you know do a large chunk like
you know even if you did eight hours
let's say every Saturday you're much
more likely to remember and retain the
knowledge if you did a little bit every
day instead of just one large thing I
mean it's kind of the same thing as
working out right if you worked out a
little bit every day your body is gonna
like that better and you're going to be
healthier in the long run than if you
just did the crazy workout once a week
for one thing you're gonna be really
sore if you try to do it like that but
your brains I think is the same way and
in terms of a little bit of practice
frequently is better than a lot of
practice infrequently so that's my
advice that's my main advice and other
than that just stick with it and I would
say try your best to do the exercises on
your own first
because you can definitely find answers
for everything you know you can find it
out there but I don't you're losing
something if you just try to get answers
from other people to quickly write your
programming is it's not necessarily just
about knowing syntax and things like
that but it's problem-solving if you're
good problem solver all that other stuff
can be figured out you know that can be
looked up but if you know we'll have all
the syntax memorized but you're not a
good problem solver you you end up you
won't be good you won't make good things
because every time you're faced with a
new problem you you won't be able to you
gonna be able to solve it so anyway
those are my
if I thought about it more maybe I'd
have better advice for you but just kind
of off the top of my head just a little
bit every day
and try to do as much as you can on your
own don't let yourself get stuck on one
problem for a really really long time
like if you you know if you're stuck on
one algorithm for days then I'd say you
know just move on right but don't give
up after five minutes right and I mean
it'll be up to your level of patience I
guess to decide at what point exactly
you would look you know try to get help
but I think you just get more out of it
if you to really try to do the work
yourself
okay
all right I was just looking I was
almost to the bottom of the live chat so
I just wanted to scan it really quite
see if there's anything else that I
should answer right now before we move
on
okay this is useful John Hanson says you
can just update to the latest jQuery is
fully backwards compatible that's
awesome
John also asks have you ever used the
step function built into Chrome
developer tools for JavaScript debug
debugging it helps pinpoint yeah
actually I have used it I don't use it
often my like fall back is always
console.log right I know everybody says
that there's better ways to do it but
it's just when you have a bug in you're
frustrated that's not really the time
that you want to try out something new
and like have even more trouble trying
to figure out a new technique so you
just fall back on console look but
anyway I'm there's so much stuff going
on here that actually might be might be
useful all right let me start up my
Pomodoro session again and let's I just
thought of this I had my live chat on
the on this the screen on the side and
so I'm constantly looking to the side
I'm never really looking at the camera
so now I'm gonna move my live chat up to
the top of my middle screen my main
monitor and then that way it'll be
easier to just appear like I'm not
talking like off to the side all the
time and I'll be more in line with the
mic so all right let's see oh okay I
know what we're gonna do I'm very
curious to see which of these errors is
there no matter what we do
if anybody listens to Spotify the
throwback Thursday playlist this week I
was it was a good one it reminds me of
when I was in probably sixth grade
seventh grade something like that so a
lot of memories of former days and Spice
Girls were a big deal there were three
Spice Girls songs on there so I remember
how much everyone loved them interesting
it's possible that I removed out
carousel I remove the code for the out
care or so but didn't get everything
let's check this out
hero slider aisle carousel what - F
which is yeah I can definitely get rid
of that because we're not we don't even
have that on the page anymore all that
stuff okay and main content so it's the
end it's at the end of the main content
I don't know if that's gonna it's gonna
let us check this out in this file but
it's worth a shot
let's this main master yeah but scroll
down now we'll have to check out the
main content that component we'll do
that later I'm not worried about it but
at least we saw that in fact a lot of
the errors are probably caused by what
we're trying to bring in all right let's
try then to use let's try to go with the
newer version of materialized and let's
bring in a newer version of jQuery and
see if we can I don't want to load two
at once so let's see where that other
version was so much stuff
where are they pulling that in
whoa maybe I'm not bringing jQuery in
anywhere this was commented out that's
interesting it's possible that jQuery is
being brought in somewhere else let me
let me check because I don't know why I
would have completely commented out J
quick
thank is this and whoa tickly tickly -
unless what that is and this is okay
that's just our materialize it's
Facebook stuff interesting let's go to
our network JavaScript
see here we go so we do have jQuery I
have no idea what version of jQuery this
is jQuery 1.10.10 in it alright let's
check our jQuery thought Min Dutch ass
it's in the head
we should be able to see this why are we
seeing this
okay I guess it's being brought in by
something in here
meta data
let's check out where this metadata is
coming from
you
actually let's check out shake this out
soon and see mater there we go metadata
one is coming from here
okay so we have
all right I'm I'm checking the live chat
real quick see if anyone said anything
okay
how much I'm not sure what's getting
pulled in here
I mean I assumed that this was where
everything was getting pulled in from I
could check it again okay so this
favorite shortcut icons is this here
so between viewport and favorite
shortcut icons everything is getting
pulled in by this eye so I assume so all
of this so all of this is getting pulled
in from somewhere else
interesting
okay all right so Umberto says he's
never seen that so he's guessing that
it's something from my CMS I yeah let's
I'm gonna try one more thing
oops
I don't want that us once that and let's
see Wow there we go
let's see where else we can find this
okay
Wow this this is in a lot of places I
don't think the tests these seem like
they're all tests so let's scroll up a
bit test as inflated for control
I don't share this one up
okay
this does look like a lot of what was
being yeah you know what this is not I
don't think this is being used anymore
because I've removed this code unless
there's some part of the site that is
still being used that I don't have found
which is possible but in any case this
is not where that's being brought in
front you can see this this site is kind
of a maze with all the stuff going on
these all look like they're tests
ooh
it was fine page layout
just feel like following a trail here
wait a second why is that already in
there yeah all right
being able to search through all those
the whole project at once is so useful
all right
I think
this is not what we're looking for all
right so let's go back to what we had
before
what are you looking at here
before we looking for
jQuery is so we want to find
it's a page layout PB test SPX and then
CMS login we could try CMS login or PB
test all right
you would think that a test page would
not be something live but this is the
file structure and this is weird in the
names of files so I'm not gonna take
take for granted that that would is
probably not anything live let's try it
out
last one which I think it was that yeah
all right let's see
actually not I think about it I do I
would have all the login stuff here so
let me open this up in an incognito
window so that I get rid of all the
login stuff I mean I probably should
worry about the login stuff at some
point because people are still gonna
have to you know login but most people
won't so for now just to make
troubleshooting easier we're gonna try
to not have all this stuff load
hopefully it doesn't load for users who
who aren't logged in there we go
well
that's interesting
all right let's check out elements [ __ ]
jQuery wow it is still loading this
that's interesting it's not in there
anyway you know those those test files
were actually now that I think about it
they're probably testing what gets
rendered so that's not where we want to
look anyway we're interested in where
this this metadata is I'm sure we
bringing this in here at all no no I
forgot we're bringing it in from the
other place okay
okay
I'm not sure I'm not sure right now
where that is coming from so yeah let's
let's try to do something and then I can
search for that later on actually let me
see I'm Barrett oh saying a lot of stuff
and I know then he knows c-sharp so let
me check out what he's saying yeah it
says whoa are they importing them in
each page individually this one is not
using master that's a relief to hear
that it's not being used no wonder
people don't like dotnet MBC is much
better organized in my opinion yeah yeah
and you know what honestly it's it's the
organization of a lot of stuff is not
great a lot of our older stuff is just
not great so it's it's not even
necessarily the fact that it's dotnet
it's just there's a lot of stuff going
on on top of like the Ektron system and
then we had it modified I mean I wasn't
here for this from from what I've heard
when it was first put in place it was
then modified by the company that set it
up with some some custom things then
people that worked here tried to patch
it up and fix it and make it do other
things and so there's a lot of stuff
going on and there's no consistency in
naming or anything it's um
there are literally pages that someone
like winning and viewed source and
copied all this stuff and then use that
as the template for a page and then
popped in so it's just weird there's
weird stuff going on so we're gonna run
into stuff like this so but I mean I
like I you know the whole point of this
stream like I frequently say is just to
see what it's like you know what my day
is like and I imagine I'm not the only
developer that
to come in and work with legacy systems
and you know can't just start from
scratch so the last project and the
project before that we were able to
basically start from scratch and just
build it up and that's awesome we can
make all the decisions on how we want to
build it unfortunately for this one we
can't so it's definitely it's fun to try
to have to hunt for things and see how
it was done as long as I can find it in
the end it's it's fun but it can make
things slow and frustrating all right so
let's um let's try bringing in another
version of jQuery and let's just see
what happens so I think I have
materialized most of that below here huh
yeah some materialized here I guess I
can get rid of that and I can get rid of
that and they had whoops
under getting started I think they had a
link yeah so let's just use this for now
since that's the one that they were
recommending and I don't want to like in
production use two versions of jQuery
but I just want to see what's what we
can do right now to get things at least
working a little bit and then try to
mess mess around from there and see if
we can get something that works it's not
working
oh okay we got some different things now
mmm
I do wonder why while we're getting some
of this stuff whoops
I'm wondering where this is coming from
interesting
this shouldn't be pulled in right now
right maybe maybe there's this stuff
that we put in down here is pulling this
ends though oh yeah nondescript stuff
we're not in the main one sorry I was
looking at the wrong thing yet you need
to go to the main nav
so actually I think yeah it's probably
coming from here we're still pulling
these in
it's
fixes
okay
yeah I think it's this
okay
actually it shouldn't be right where do
we put this uh so this is inside the
header so it should not be outputting
anything outside the header right this
is where it ends
all right my timer is up so I'm gonna
finish this up in just a minute
I just want to see what is over here I
think what it was probably happening is
that side nav takes up space and then
the JavaScript in materialized pushes it
over and that JavaScript we're getting
an error and it's not running and so
this is staying out so it's pushing
everything over and so that's why I mean
this button doesn't work right because
this never initializes since
everything's pushed over that's why this
is going off the side there so I think
that's our problem our main problem is
the JavaScript just is not running
because it looks like all the CSS is
fine right we're still getting we were
getting some weird stuff from what's
already there so you can see on hover
it's changing the blue which it
shouldn't do so but other than those few
things our CSS is fine
it's just the JavaScript it's not
running
can I try
let's try
wanna try this with our new version of
jQuery and see if it makes a difference
okay no difference there and last thing
and then I'll be done let's not use this
version of jQuery and instead let's
uncomment that
no still still not working
although actually this is I had
forgotten that this is the way it works
but whatever version of jQuery we load
last seems to be the version that it's
trying to use so let's get to know I
want to get rid of this because really I
mean this is the only error that we're
getting right now
so I also figure out where this is and
remove it
the others checking to see if it wasn't
that al carousel wasn't loading anywhere
else but I'm gonna see it okay all right
now it's time for questions and I'm I
think I got through a lot of them so it
probably won't be a very long
question-and-answer session so if you
have a question you think about asking
it put it in there now because once I
get to the bottom I'll probably go on
for like three minutes longer than I
should and then I'll end and turn the
stream off but I don't want you to miss
out in case you want to ask something so
if you're not interested in the question
answer session thank you so much for
watching and I'll be back tomorrow so
hopefully you can join in then if you
don't have a question but you are
knowledgeable and like to help answer
questions that would be awesome it's
definitely way better when we get a
variety of of opinions and in answers
right I mean we can't all be experts at
everything so it's better when we have
people that know about different areas
all right so let's let's go oh you know
what I just remembered
I told you I told you all at the
beginning that I was going to show you
what I did on project two because I
thought it was really interesting so let
me take I'm only gonna spend at most
five minutes on this so I'm setting my
five minute timer so I don't keep going
for too long and let me show you as
quickly as I can what I've done so
here's our service request form okay and
I've added in a few things so now
they're automatically if you mark a
field is required and asterisk is going
to be there so that's I don't know it's
it's a simple improvement but I'll show
you how I did it in in react I mean it's
kind of cool it's not super complex but
I just like how it's done also I've
added this if you click
photography now you have two more
required fields that pop up so and some
of them don't and some of them do but
this was some feedback I got earlier
today that the video people and the
people in charge of photography both
want more information but it doesn't
apply to everything so I thought that
was kind of cool so I just want to show
you oh the other thing that I did was I
changed the field the validation so I
don't know if you remember I think this
happened once before if I were to do
something like this and have a space it
would have marked the name as being
invalid so it's not it wasn't obvious
from the name of the validation that it
would do that but it did so I had to
change it from like alpha to is words
something like that and if you change it
to is words then it lets you put spaces
so a lot of these I just removed the
validation completely because there
really wasn't anything built into
formzee that would fit because really in
these you know primary target audience I
they could type a paragraph that had
numbers letters special characters at
that point what am I really you know
trying to validate there and remember
write the validation client-side is
really nothing nothing to do with
security because people can get around
it it's more just to be helpful to the
user so anyway so I decided to take off
the validation except for some obvious
places like email phone actually I took
it off a phone too because somebody
might put want to put their extension
here so they might write ext period and
then a number which would be invalid so
anyway so I took it off of a lot of them
but it's really nice that it will be on
email though and then that way it'll
force people if they accidentally mess
up their email or something I mean it
won't check if they misspell something
but at least it'll if they left out a
dot or
something really important would it
would let them know all right so here's
how I did it whoops okay so I've added
in in in the data for the check boxes
this is the coolest thing I did so I'm
going to show this just to make sure I
get it in I've added in this conditional
fields that's an array of objects and
you see the objects are exactly the same
data that I'm passing in up here for the
other text boxes right so I've added
into the service request form here where
we have check boxes and right so here's
where we're pulling in the check boxes
there's some more space here so you can
see so within this right where we're
checking for all that data in here the
check box data in here and where we're
looping over that and when we get down
to here I check to see if there are
conditional fields if there are
conditional fields then I check to see
through this state ok I check to see if
the check box is checked
that's what this does okay that's not
really obvious right away but that's
what this is doing so it checks the
check box and so if there are
conditional fields for that particular
check box data and then if the check box
is checked then it renders everything
that's under conditional fields so since
it's an array of objects we can do a map
on there and then we map and we just
pull in that same formzee text component
that we've used at the top for the you
know for the name email and all that and
then we just pass in our props and since
we we did it the same way I guess this
is almost completely the same
I've added some different styles just
because of where they're at in between
those checkboxes and I've also added in
for the required we have for the
floating label Texas field field
required if if it's true then we do
field name plus and asterisk if it's
false we just put field name so that's
how I did those asterisks as well yeah
so that's how I ended up doing it I
tried a couple different ways before
that that didn't work and then it
finally hit me that this was the
simplest way and it would work and I
can't believe I didn't think of it
sooner so I actually tried like passing
in all of this stuff as data in a string
which was ridiculous and obviously
didn't work and I tried putting this in
in our icon check box thing but then I
would have to been passing information
back and forth about the state of of
those text fields right because remember
they're controlled components so right
we're putting in the value whatever gets
typed in there goes into state and then
the value of that input comes from state
right so I'd have to pass that back and
forth from the parent component which
was service request AAS so that was
ridiculous as well when the simple thing
was just to put it in there
unfortunately that was the third thing I
thought of but it was still cool to go
through here and just kind of see what's
possible and not possible so anyway just
thought I'd share that with you all the
it's all on github now so if you want to
check it out a little bit more detail
you can do that all right now I will go
to the questions and let's see I got to
figure out where I left off it
okay Carlos asked what version of jQuery
I'm using I assume that you saw
embarrassed this looks like 1.1 yeah so
there are multiple types so there was I
commented out one one point eleven
something and then so it was falling
back to an older version one point ten
something to the evidently I was using
one point ten without realizing it at
first and then you know we tried we
tried at version three nothing gave us
the result that we wanted so off to do
some more troubleshooting
okay Evo says or I bow I'm not sure I'm
not sure which way to pronounce that
it's Ivo says hi Jessie long time no see
the good old memories working with
asp.net in school still haunt me to this
day
hey I just noticed my camera didn't
freeze up at all during the stream so
hopefully it lasts and I'm still going
to try to use my phone next time but I'm
glad I didn't have to restart it
all right so uh Abdul Azeez says hi
Jesse is it not possible to work with
the computer I see you are working with
two computers another question is what
is the difference between free code camp
and github
okay so Ebola answered the saying github
is a code repository storing code and
free code campus community of developers
yeah yeah that's that's pretty much it
right you can store your code using git
on github
yeah and free code camp is a lot of
different things go on I think its main
the main thing it's known for is its
courses so it's coding exercises but
there's also a lot more going on now so
they have a really active forum they
have medium publication so lots of blogs
and then of course we have the YouTube
channel now that's really picked up and
we we have a lot of videos every week
and yeah so it's just we a loved one or
not and then there are also groups free
code camp groups that meet up frequently
so all over the world so this it's a lot
we got a lot going on and also I'm not I
don't understand what you mean by your
first question about working with two
computers are you saying I think I'm
trying to see if you can see my other
computer in the background if that's
what you're talking about I do mainly
just work with one computer and that's
fine one computer with three monitors
and then the computer behind me is just
an old Windows laptop connected to an
external monitor so I don't go crazy
trying to do things on one screen and I
just use that for testing and in fact
something happened and it isn't
connecting to the internet anymore so it
hasn't been able to connect to the
for at least six months so I really
haven't even used it and I think I'm
better off because it's so old I'm
afraid it'll get a virus if I try to
connect to the internet anyway it's just
and it's super slow so I don't really
need to use it that much anymore because
I have browser stack for testing and
it's faster for me just to open browser
stack on this computer and test then to
get that thing started up and connected
anyway I assume that's what you were
referring to if not let me know and
maybe clarify a little bit more for me
nova glow asks what kind of degree or
training did you get to become a
developer okay so my training was for
the most part informal I do have I have
a video on my channel the links in the
description on how I became a front-end
developer so if you want a more in-depth
answer I think that's maybe like I don't
know a 10 to 15 minute video of me
talking about it but basically other
than a little bit of training in HTML
and CSS in high school and one
programming course in college where we
use C++ all of my training has been just
online either taking mostly free courses
online reading you know reading blogs
reading free JavaScript books
documentation things like that and just
learning by trial and error on a lot of
projects I was lucky enough to have
basically the role of a subcontract
subcontractor for a lot of things so I
got a lot of work doing just so many
different things you know relating to
websites everything from writing blogs
for companies doing SEO work all the way
to JavaScript stuff and I get paid for
that and I was able to spend a lot of
time learning and
didn't have to worry about billing
clients or trying to market myself or
going to meetings or anything like that
because I had someone else that was
doing all that I got paid a little less
because of it but it freed me up to
spend a lot of time being able to learn
and get paid while I was doing it so
that's that's mostly where I really went
through a lot of my learning now that
I'm employed full-time as a front-end
developer I've learned a lot while I'm
going through projects and sometimes if
things are a little bit slower I can
spend some time like doing more targeted
learning so doing some free code camp
exercises or catching up on you know
videos from from conferences that are on
YouTube and things like that sometimes
I'm able to take some time you know
maybe like on my lunch break or
something I watch some tutorial videos
so just here and there I picked things
up you know when I needed although I am
taking a Udacity nano degree course
that's about the closest thing to formal
training that I've that I've had so
anyway like I said you can watch that
video too if you want to hear some more
about it and I didn't mention my I just
looked at your question again you asked
what kind of degree I had I have a
degree in business so it's not really
related to confuse
whoa Evo Eva just had a great idea I
love this idea so Eva says you can also
try to hack it by overriding the jQuery
nsj file in the UX folder but that is
just the ultimate hack I like that that
is like it's it's a little bit sneaky
but it's it's so simple that's like the
I still would like to know where it's
coming from cuz it'll always bug me if I
don't find out but just to get things to
the point where we aren't loading a
bunch of different versions of jQuery
and we have a new version that's that's
a great idea I'll just keep a backup of
the other version in case it breaks a
bunch of stuff which it shouldn't but
all right I think that's that's the best
idea that I've heard today
John Hanson says would it be a good idea
to comment out the template variables
then bring them back one by one unless
there are too many of them yeah actually
I thought about doing that I think if we
had more time I probably would have done
it because that right we're kind of
getting towards the end there I'm gonna
say I'm I'm gonna do a lot of a lot of
searching so we'll see we'll see what's
going on I think I'm right after the
stream I'm gonna stop working on on my
work stuff and I'm gonna start working
on my project for Udacity but then
tomorrow when I come in I think all
morning I'll either be searching for the
answer to this or I'll be finishing up
some things on that Resource Center on
project to which there's not really that
much left to do but hopefully I'll find
it and then we can actually work on
something I'm running out of titles to
put in my video I just put it in today's
video about the side nav I'll just have
to put part two at the end I guess
oh okay
John Hanson said I could browse our hard
reload to clear the cache if it's
holding on to jQuery version actually
that's a good idea but I think I have it
yeah yeah I have it so that if I have
dev tools open nothing gets cached so
that's really helpful so check out that
setting if you if you're not familiar
with it already because you almost never
want the cache working when you're
developing so so nothing should have
been cached I'll probably try it though
later on because you never know I mean
it's uh it's always worth trying too
hard refresh just in case Shay says hey
Jesse thanks for these thanks for the
videos would you mind giving a brief
description of doing local development
versus using code pen or cloud 9 etc or
could you point to the best place to
read up on how to do a simple project
locally set up the local O's for testing
etc okay yeah I'll try to explain this
briefly also so at the end of those
sentences is etc' period right which is
etc now this is totally unrelated to
code but you may have heard from
previous streams that I used to teach
Latin right and that's a Latin word at
cetera but it always bugs me when I hear
it because everybody except for one
person I've ever heard pronounces it etc
but if I were teaching Latin and I
wanted to say that I would say etc right
so I don't want to say it like that and
sound weird so I still say etc but
anyway it always bothers me so this I
basically still want to know does anyone
else pronounce it like the proper Latin
way I'm wondering especially like people
whose
maybe a Romance language is their first
language I'm thinking they would be more
likely to pronounce it properly and
maybe it's just Americans speaking
English they can't pronounce it right I
don't know anyway
and Latin has multiple pronunciations
depending on what type of Latin you're
studying so I guess it's I shouldn't be
too weird about it all right so I'm
gonna try to take there are a couple
parts to this question so I guess I'll
talk about the doing like cloud
development like in browser development
with code pen and cloud 9 so I would say
this code pen in cloud 9 urns are in two
different classes right so in terms of
ease of use I'd say there's like a
spectrum right and the easiest would be
something like code pen or jsfiddle
would also be in there I think there's
some other ones but basically you just
can write code and immediately see the
result usually you have like three
windows one for HTML one for CSS and one
for JavaScript like three little frames
and then there's another frame that
shows the result it's super easy so
basically you're just working with three
files it does let you import other
libraries and it's actually really easy
to do in code pen I haven't used a
fiddle in a long time so it might be
easy in there as well but there are some
limitations right I mean you're you're
limited I would never do a really big
project in there right with that needed
a complex folder structure as last time
I use something on code pen like you
can't host files there you have to
import them also so it's limited but
it's really easy you just need a browser
to get started and then a little bit
harder to use is cloud9 or things like
cloud 9 where you have what basically
looks like what you see on on the screen
right now but it runs in your browser
all right which is actually kind of
interesting because this
is running on chromium right I think the
s code is an electron app so technically
this is running in a browser - right so
but anyway you you all probably know
what I'm talking about right it's not
running in this is running on my
computer essentially like a native
desktop app but cloud9 would run in your
browser you'd open up your browser you
type in the URL it's c9 IO login and
there you are and you'd see something
like this and you'd actually see I got
rid of it on Visual Studio code but at
the bottom you would see a terminal that
you could type real commands and it's a
Linux server so you could type in all
your normal Linux commands you can load
things with NPM you have all your folder
structure over here and you have your
code here and you also could have
another window to have the live preview
and you could split the window out in
fact and you know put it on another
screen if you want but it basically
completely mimics your local development
environment you're still somewhat
limited because I guess it depends on
what version if you pay for you know
faster server more space it could be
really nice but you still have you
you're going through the internet right
so there's always going to be that I
guess would you call latency right then
that lag I mean it's not bad if you had
a good connection but you have to be
connected so you couldn't you couldn't
develop you know offline like that
the Third Way and then maybe there's
more ways that I don't know about is
you've developed locally and I may I say
that's the hardest because you have to
set up cloud 9 sets up a lot for you but
locally you have to set everything up
like if you want to develop let's say
react like we are doing for our last two
projects you'd have to have a computer I
mean it doesn't really matter if it's
Windows or Linux or Mac but you'd have a
computer you need to be able to install
node
in npm and then you need to install all
your your other packages yourself it's
on your machine it's taking up your
space on your computer like you know you
have to have a separate terminal I mean
a lot of like Visual Studio code comes
with the terminal and stuff but to be
honest with you I'm Way more satisfied
with using I term two separately then
using this I mean especially if I want
to do some stuff in the terminal and I'm
not actually using atom or Visual Studio
code I don't have to open that up just
to do it so so now you have two
different programs right you're running
us you got to run a server on your own
machine to do local development so you
can see like it just grows in complexity
the cool thing though about cloud 9 and
things like cloud 9 are that you could
potentially do like real development
with you know loading and PIM packages
and all kinds of cool things that you
couldn't do with code pen but you could
do it on something like a Chromebook
where you know you normally don't have
access to load something like node and
an NPM and all that stuff on a
Chromebook I know there are ways to
unlock it but let's say you didn't want
to void your warranty you could do it in
browser potentially you could do it on a
tablet it would probably be harder
depending on what kind of tablet you had
but you know you could do it there I've
never tried to open up cloud 9 on a
phone but that I mean it might be
possible so anyway hopefully that helps
that ended up being a really long answer
I probably could have made a whole video
out of that but anyway that's that's my
opinion on that also the other part of
that question was could you point to the
best place to read up on how to do
simple project locally set up a local
host for testing I would
trying to think where I saw I I would
like to do some videos on that but I'm
they're not doing them yet as you all
you all know who's been watching I
really want to do a lot more videos but
I just have not had time so I don't know
when that'll happen but until then I
think we'll stern who does the what is
it learn code Academy YouTube channel
will stern made a bunch of videos on
setting up development environments and
things but they're kind of a little bit
older than maybe a few years old so but
it'll get a lot of the concepts will be
there right I mean he goes into like
webpack but he also goes over gulp and
grunt and things like that so you'll
you'll get an idea for what's out there
and how to do it and then you can maybe
read up on some newer things if you want
to but you should be able to get the
basics there you know if you like that I
don't I don't really know of anything
offhand like for you to read I'm sure
there's a lot of good stuff out there I
just learned how to do all that from
YouTube videos but that's a good place
to go and let me know if you have any
other question if you try it out and
have other questions and stuff just let
me know in the live chat or you can
message me on Twitter or something and
help you out if I can okay just a few
more things here in the live chat I'm
down to the bottom now Ali says let's
see okay this was in response to someone
else's question in the live chat so I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna read that okay
ebo says sometimes with these kinds of
projects I just feel it saves you a lot
of stress and hassle if you just start
over I definitely agree and if I could I
would just start developing the new site
right away honestly I think it's
somewhat of a waste of time
for me to do this now because I hope to
redo the main site within the next like
year or so and oh hey I think my
daughter is at the door so hold on a
second me open the door look you can see
Thanks there you go yeah the cameras
right over that green light is yeah so
what do you think you're gonna say
something there the people on YouTube on
YouTube there are 21 people watching
right now yeah so this is Gemma my
daughter Gemma and this is my son
Raphael up here so they they just
brought me some food because I'm gonna
stay here at the office late and work on
my my project for Udacity so it's a lot
easier to get worked on here at home
there's too many kids I normally like
having all the kids around but not if at
work to do just let you come in by
yourself but I kind of couldn't do well
I'm gonna finish up my youtube show now
do you guys have to go
okay alright that was fun
um yeah my daughter Gemma wants to be
like a YouTube chef like make cakes and
stuff so there's a youtuber named Gemma
whose show her show is cupcake Gemma and
she has like some bakeries in England
and my daughter Gemma loves that show so
well maybe one day I'll make Gemma
YouTube channel I bought her all kind of
baking stuff for her birthday it was at
the end of August so so we'll see anyway
I'll give you back to the coating now to
only only have just maybe two questions
left
oh okay so the last thing Evo was saying
it's better just to start over sometimes
okay now I remember already basically my
opinion is that I should not be trying
to fix this site that instead I should
just start on the new site and we could
probably get a new site up and running
and like probably I'm gonna say like six
months not that it would take me six
months but just there are so many people
that are going to be involved in making
decisions on that that I know it will
take forever to get approval for stuff
so because really we've already done
stuff even on this stream that we could
use to build our own site like if we
took if we took what we did for that
project one right and use next J as some
server-side rendering with next and and
react and just linked it up with a
content management system through an API
like WordPress or something else then we
basically have the site I mean the main
site right now Franciscan ddu has like
three thousand plus pages maybe more
than that but in reality they're you
know we don't create all those pages
right we create a home page template and
then just a few other templates for the
different types of pages and then those
just
populated with data from the content
management system so the hardest part of
that whole process would just be getting
the data that's in the extra on CMS
right now and getting it transferred to
something better I don't want it to stay
on there I don't want it to be hosted on
campus anymore because it's it's slow
the time the first byte is just
unacceptable so that's the biggest thing
and once I have that down actually
developing the site it's not really a
big deal so to me you know spending
weeks on this is just kind of it's time
that I could that I could already have
that other site ready so I mean yeah
I'll get this done a little bit faster
and there'll be a slight increase in
speed it'll look nicer but right now
it's just like it's it's like putting a
bandaid on something like underneath
still needs it's it's still damaged it
still needs work it's you know it's
still slow yeah so anyway that's that's
my opinion about this and so and I'm I'm
comfortable saying this on YouTube
because I've already said this to my
boss and this other people that that
work here's but that's how it is right
when you when you work with other people
you can't always do it however you want
to do it sometimes you got a you know
you got to wait and you got to do other
things and anyway so we'll do the best
we can you know and I think it's gonna
it's going to be good and people are
gonna be impressed users are gonna have
a great a much better experience so is
it is it the best thing we could do
right now
no but it's gonna it's gonna be better
ok Tony yes how long have you been
coding I think like five years I don't
know every time I get asked this after
think about it
I just need to write it down and just
stick it you know on my desk let me try
to think so I've been at this position
as a front-end developer for a little
over two years before that yeah before
that I think it was about three years
that I was doing some website related
stuff so I wasn't really doing like
advanced coding stuff the whole time
when I started out it was you know kind
of maybe just customizing some WordPress
themes just really minimal CSS work you
know minimal HTML almost no JavaScript
and then I started to get more into it
so I started a lot better with CSS and
then started getting in JavaScript and
now obviously you all see what I do I've
been you know I've been streaming all
summer so you know I think you have a
good idea of where I'm at now so but
basically it's been like a five-year
span of but I would say three years I've
been like really trying to learn
JavaScript as much as I could you know I
can't always do what I want because it
depends on the projects that I have but
three years really for the JavaScript
but just in terms of like web design and
development in general five I did do
stuff here and there before that and as
I mentioned earlier I have a video on my
own channel and I think the title was
how I became a front-end developer and I
go into it more in terms of like the
points in my life where I actually did
do web development work because there
were some other other points like in
high school and college and stuff that I
did some stuff with that
okay Ali says code pen allows asset
hosting if you use projects rather than
pens okay cool
is that a new feature did I just miss
that before like I said I haven't used
code pen in a while but that that's
really cool and is that a paid feature
or can you do that on the free version
now anyway that'd be good to know so I
said earlier that you can't host files
on code pen but I was mistaken so I
guess there is a way I'm not sure how to
do it but I think there is a way so
that's that's good that's really awesome
I see a lot of people doing the early
free code camp lessons when they're
first going into code pen aren't sure
how to get images in there sometimes I
see questions about that so okay Ali
says you get one free project okay so
you can do one one free project and
actually host files there and then I
guess if I don't know how much it costs
but you could you know get the pro
version and have more okay I see several
people were saying that my kids are cute
thank you
yeah I think I did an alright job on on
the kids so far none of them are I
haven't messed any of them up yet
hopefully I don't my oldest is only
eight so I have a while to go okay
nobody said I didn't know you had
children I actually have four children
so you saw my oldest too
so Raphael Gemma and then I've Ambrose
who's three and Cordelia who's about to
turn one in a few weeks she'll turn one
on October 5th so yeah so I'm busy
alright I've gotten to the bottom of the
live chat so I'll be back tomorrow
and hopefully I'll have this to the
point where we're not getting errors and
we can actually start to work on things
a little bit more alright so huh
nope you just said I am shocked you
shocked that I have four kids okay now
I'm getting a few more things in the
last here's Ali says that's impressive
how often you stream and have four kids
me actually so me being able to stream
this much is really due to my boss
letting me stream at work which is
really awesome and he's a smart guy and
he so he realized right away that me
streaming would would not only be good
for me and good for you know hopefully
good for you all if you know you can
learn learn about what I do or at least
learn from my mistakes
and but it would also be free publicity
for the University so just to put it in
perspective I think the university's
YouTube account has maybe 20,000
subscribers free code camp has over
200,000 subscribers so it's it's a
little bit of like you know hey this
will be good for university but also and
this was unexpected at first I've gotten
so much help on my projects by pool
requests and by you all you know helping
that it's really been a huge benefit to
to the University you know to my
department and in all our projects so I
hope that he continues to let me do this
and so far everybody's excited I I
mentioned you you all in meetings
frequently and sometimes even by name
and I'll say you know hey so-and-so
submitted a pull request and it was
awesome or you know and everybody's
really excited about that so your your
you don't get to interact with other
people here at the department but they
know that you're there and that
help and they're all happy and excited
about it so anyway so I hope I can keep
doing this if it ever happened that it
wasn't allowed to do this at work
anymore then I probably wouldn't be able
to stream this frequently I just have to
see it at that point I would I wouldn't
want to stop streaming but you know it
would be different the schedule would be
different the projects would be
different but hopefully that won't
happen and I'll keep I'll keep doing
this but yeah so that's how I can stream
with four kids
let's see us Sarat says can I be as good
as you in two months with six hours of
coding a day with consistency I may be I
mean it just it depends on how fast of a
learner you are what your background is
already like what level you're out in
terms of your skills with coding I so I
don't know there's going to be it in
terms of like just coding you can
definitely get so like if you wanted to
focus on just react and build react
stuff you could definitely get there but
there's gonna be like a broad area that
you just can't get without time and that
there's certain things like having
persevered through like projects that
are really hard or dealt with clients
that are really difficult or like
there's so many things that you can't
just do it you know it just it's
something that happens to you and it it
makes you better it changes the way you
look at things so things like that you
obviously can't get by just training
hard for you know for a couple of months
but like as I was trying to say a few
seconds ago like if you wanted to focus
on a specific area you could definitely
get as good or better than me quickly
you know my five years of coding has
been spread out over so many different
things like I did a lot of search engine
optimization work copywriting and a lot
of WordPress stuff I was trying to learn
angular at one
time it's just been spread out over so
many areas that I definitely think it's
possible to get really good better than
me at one particular area if you were to
focus on that whereas I never really was
able to focus until I started working
here and really narrow down like this is
going to be our stack this is what we're
going to use and being able to commit to
it which right now it's basically
committing to reiax you know when you
commit it's tough because you're
basically saying no to everything else
but by doing that it allows me to focus
and get better it allows the people
around me that are going to work with me
to be able to know and for me to be
predictable in my work so anyway so yeah
it's entirely possible but I would say
it's only possible in the sense that you
would have to concentrate on one area
and and there are some experiences you
just can't recreate so how much that
contributes to me being a better coder
or not I don't know but I mean I'll tell
you this like when you bring down
somebody a business's email system for
three days you definitely never ever
mess with MX records again without
copying them down first so like there
are things like that that just like see
her into your mind like something that
needs to be done and yes I did do that
before so it was it was a business in a
big city in the United States that made
a lot of money and I have no idea how
much money that I actually cost them but
I I did pay for them to hire somebody
else to fix it so and that other person
made a lot more per hour than I did so
that but I think I got off easy on that
because I still worked with that client
for a long time after that it's actually
one of my best clients so anyway so let
me see I don't think there's any other
okay one more
course keep you in more questions hey
it's fine
[Music]
okay so Hodor says quick question can
link your coding environment which
extensions are you using on on paceman I
think there's a command to get a list of
extensions okay yeah I'll have to there
there is a way to get a list of
extensions I'll probably get you the
atom extensions because I haven't really
loaded anything on Visual Studio code so
that wouldn't be a useful list but I'll
have to get my list of atom extensions
and I'll put them I'll probably make a
gist and have it in in github
you know linked up to my profile so I'll
have to remember to do that I'm I don't
know if I'll get it done you know this
week but it'll be on my list of stuff
and I'll make sure I say something on
the live stream about it no BS is what
time in your country here 156 a.m. no
beer are you in India or close to India
because I'm pretty sure that's the time
zone there it is four o'clock here yeah
it's a 358 p.m. where I'm at I'm in
Eastern Standard Time so there's the
same time zone as New York and the east
coast of the United States oh cool no
beer is in Bangladesh so yeah I've had
enough viewers from India that I I
always remember what time it is in India
and when I tell people like they look at
me really weird like why would you know
what time it is in India so I think it's
cool it's cool to know that let's see
okay zanny says why are you using
classic ASP because I'm forced to that's
so this is it's a pre-existing site that
that
kind of old and I just have to make the
best of it so I'm just gonna try to
clean it up make it faster make it more
user-friendly and so I can't there's
some things that I can't change on it
and there's a lot of things that just
aren't really worth it to dig into
because this site won't last much longer
if I'm not working on a new site
sometime within the next year I will be
very surprised because I've been I've
been planning it like since before I
even got the job here I remember before
the interview I did a huge report on all
the things that would change on this
site and I turned that in on my in my
interview to the person who's now my
boss and yes and I actually I went
through I think I even had code samples
of like code that they could use to
change the site right now so I think
that that helped me get the job they
were they like that but I'm ready it's
been like over two years that I wanted
to change the site so I don't want to
wait another year so anyway that's why
I'm stuck with with the classic ASP and
I'm not really interested in trying to
figure out how to change it
so it is it is what it is right now but
we're gonna make the best of it and and
try to make this site I want to try to
shock people that are used to this site
with the new thing I want them to think
that I completely redid the site but in
fact we just are gonna change a few
things you know to make it better so but
I really enjoy doing things that other
people think you can't be done right so
I mean I know you all realized that
these things are possible but a lot of
people who aren't really into web
development sometimes just they just
assume that things can't be done because
they may have been told by at some point
by a developer like all we can't do that
and who knows why that developer said
that maybe they just meant you don't
have the money for me to do that or
I don't have the time or maybe they
didn't have the skills to do it or
didn't want to do it who knows but it's
happened frequently at the University
here that people have said I'll say well
why don't we do this and I say all I
know we can and sometimes it's literally
as easy as 10 minutes in dev tools and
you can find a fix those moments are
really awesome when I get to see
somebody sits like I wanted to do this
for years and you just did it in 10
minutes like those are really cool those
are the moments that I like I write down
or I usually don't write it down I put a
note and Google keep just so I remember
and then on bad days I can look at that
and say like oh I did do something
awesome but anyway I'm to the bottom of
the live chat for real this time so I am
gonna go now unless somebody sneaks a
question in there before I can be
finished but thanks again for watching
thanks for all your help and for all the
all the questions you all have great
questions today and I know I talked for
a little while on the question so sorry
sorry if I talk too much
I know occasionally I'll have people in
the comments or in the live chat telling
me I talk too much but it's not it's not
a tutorial stream you know it's it's I
like this question answer thing and I
think it's it it makes this stream more
unique if it was just me trying to teach
you how to code it would not be a great
stream because there's so much I still
need to learn but my personal experience
is unique to me and you can't get that
anywhere else so if I share that then
there might be some value here all right
so I'm going to go now I'll be back
tomorrow thank you so much for watching
and have a great day